and trying to regroup after the game one
loss daniel ponce de leon is going in
game number two the o2 pitch to lamont
wade swaying in a mess he struck him out
and a good start for daniel randy
dobneck horrific season out of this
young six and two record and
the 2.72 era
one
and two double play and the runner at
first edmond didn't know whether the
ball was caught in the air or not
look at young hitter right here at brent
rooker he's got a very solid fundamental
swing he's very strong rooker's first
home run of his big league career
probably not too far away
i don't believe it did you do that again
[Laughter]
that's that's one of the best streaks
and it's a streak of two and it's one of
the best i've ever seen
rooker with his first big league home
run and it's two to nothing twins
why am i
wasting my time doing baseball games i
should be picking stocks or doing
something i love the intensity i love
the focus it's all about just focusing
on that one pitch
and that's hit out to left o'neal over
diving and he made the catch oh what a
play tyler o'neill saves a run and maybe
two what a catch tyler o'neill full
extension in left field
what a play
and they all are gonna love this play
from tyler o'neil what a catch it's huge
i mean that play right there that saves
two runs easily completely shifts this
game and the bases are loaded for the
cardinals
they have been
one of the best in baseball
with the sax full
and tommy is
hit by the pitch
[Applause]
and with that the cardinals get on the
board he's hit two in the inning and the
cardinals get a hit by pitch with the
bases loaded and it's now a 2-1 game and
this makes it a 2-1 game
if you're gonna get hit that's the way
to do it right there
that's a good rbi turn him loose on 3-0
and let him rip taken high and it's a
walk
and with that we're tied at 2-2
[Applause]
third double play depth they pinch in at
the corners the pitch by dobneck had
slowly hit to the first baseman bear
handing the throw comes home safe
cino throwing to the catcher
and the home plate umpire said that ryan
jeffers was off the plate
and the cardinals lead 3-2
ceno made a good play bare handing the
ball throwing as hard as he could to
jeffers
they could call that a fielder's choice
i'll have to wait and see
still only one out and now here is
rangel
rivello ground ball through the hole
into left field a base hit
and one run will score it's four to two
domnick got the ground ball but with the
infield drawn in
it
slipped between donaldson and adrianza
let's see if carpenter can get into one
[Applause]
the runners lead
on three and two there they go the pitch
is taking low ball four
there's another run batted in for matt
carpenter
with the bases loaded
[Applause]
86 career rbis with the bases loaded
pitch number 16 of the at-bat is popped
up and will have a 17th pitch of course
we will the 17th pitch at the at-bat rip
foul
we will have an 18th pitch of the
advantage number 18 of the at-bat here
it comes
and it's popped up and
out of play
pitch number 19.
and weiner sends a fly ball out to
center
near the track and theo barr gets him 19
pitches in the at-bat but they need to
get one but when you get into this
situation it's it's not too late in the
game just
making a two-run game instead of a
three-run game it's still important
ground ball hit right to the second
baseman a run will come in
donaldson in from third cruise to third
2-0 the count on colton wong runners at
the corners trying to add some insurance
late
wong hits it up the middle base hit
edmond will score goldsmith to third and
colton wong delivers and that
adds to the cardinal lead to make it a
6-3 st louis lee
little breathing room links
the 1-2 blasted to left-center field and
deep on the warning track at the wall
and gone
and nelson cruz homers in the second
game of this double header and now has
made twins history yet again it's a 6-4
cardinal lead as cruz homers for the
15th time this season
but in doing so now in three
double headers this year he is homeward
in both games of the doubleheader
becoming the first twin in team history
to ever do that here is the o2 pitch
swing and a hot shot the third great
play by the cardinal third baseman long
throw got him the red bird split the
doubleheader
nice nice play by jimmy edmonds to end
this game